il s'est aujourd'hui un véritable
problème de santé publique en france
l'obésité guette les plus jeunes on
estime qu environ 10% des enfants dans
notre pays affiche une surchage
pondérale voire plus l'éducation
nationale multiplie donc les campagnes
d'information dès le plus jeune âge
exemple dans les écoles maternelles de
haute garonne en ce moment marie-pierre
samitier francis fons chez elle et toi
tu vas aller de vente et achat comme les
vendeurs le jeu consiste à équilibrer
vos pas depuis deux ans dans cette école
on apprend aux enfants quels sont les
groupes d'aliments objectif modifier les
habitudes alimentaires et lutter contre
l'augmentation de l'obésité chez les
enfants après ces séances de formation
quand on demande aux quatre ans ce qui
fait le plus grossir l'origine des
aliments savent que les biscuits au
chocolat les sodas font grossir
cette formation concerne 79 écoles
maternelles en haute-garonne et met en
garde les enfants tenter par une
alimentation trop grasse et trop sucrés
c'est pas quelque chose va supprimer au
quotidien podium c'est quand même
quelque chose qui reste c'est du plaisir
et ce qu'il faudrait changer c'est quand
même les habitudes et des parents eux
mêmes qui sont à la base de
l'alimentation animale autre école
maternelle autre jeu oui il s'agit bien
du même objectif apprendre à manger
équilibré à commencer par le petit
déjeuner qu'il ne faut jamais sauté et
puis et puis un peu de chocolat de
titres ayez tout ça on nous apprend à
bien manger à savoir un petit peu à
connaître les aliments qu'il faut manger
mais il faut aussi bouger d'accord leur
apprendre à bouger
c'est l'autre objectif de cette étude
l'obésité justement est liée à ce
phénomène là parce que c'est la mauvaise
alimentation plus la sédentarité et
disons que nous sommes à notre étude se
situe à ce niveau là dans la prévention
les enfants ou ont-ils changé leurs
habitudes après cette formation
réponse à la fin de ce mois de juin le
jour avec moi